wohin denkst du eigentlich wenig potter
sein wirklich glücklich schon ein paar
tage plötzlich seinen urgroßvater teil
gehört die bereits auf eine boccia ist
wenn man das wahrscheinlich nach dem
rezept nach dann bist du einfach der
king zu hause bin ja
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute häufige
vegetarische
türkischen liebe einfach türkische
teigtaschen porter nennt man die auf
türkisch und ich starte direkt werde
euch die ganze menge an ganz unten
infobox schreiben und zwar wirklich die
ganz genauen angaben denn im türkischen
misst man oft mit tasten dann sagt man
eine tasse davon 2000 war von schreibe
euch aber die gramm angabe hin weil ich
das auch gerade für anfänger ein
bisschen einfacher finden und man sich
einfach sicherer ist und ich starte
jetzt nehme ich mir eine große schüssel
nehme da kommt jetzt als sehr wohl schon
fast sagt milch mit ryan die solche
schönen lauf warm sein wenn da hat es
die hefe am liebsten ich gebe es sich
alles mit dazu das kommt gleich ich gebe
es viel frische hefe mit rein einfach
rein bröseln und wie gesagt die hefe hat
es in so einem warmen milieu einfach am
liebsten arbeitet sie nämlich gut und
zum arbeiten brauchen wir auch zucker
dann nehme ich puderzucker ihr könnt
auch kristallzucker nehmen aber das ist
so ein kleiner geheimtipp dass wir die
puderzucker nehmt das auch tatsächlich
habe es mal gebacken mit zog mit
kristallzucker mit puderzucker und es
ist tatsächlich so dass wenn puderzucker
verwendet der teig noch minimal florida
wird und wir wollen ja alles an
flüssigkeit rausholen was geht
[Musik]
ihr könnt das ganze gemischt dann gerne
einmal fünf bis acht minuten zurück
elektronen das nichts die hilfe schon
mal so ein bisschen arbeitet und
anschließend die restlichen zutaten
dazugeben am besten in dieser
reihenfolge also macht weiter mit der
lauwarmen dann nochmal den restlichen
zucker dazu salz würde ich jetzt noch
nicht dazu geben denn seil quasi direkt
mit hefe verträgt sich nicht so gut ich
mache das immer so dass ich seit erstmal
dann dazu gebe wenn wir das mehl
hinzufügen hier haben gehen noch
neutrales öl dann nämlich sonnenblumenöl
oder auch mal rapsöl einfach mit rein so
und jetzt kommt das mehl da ist es nicht
immer ein kino bei diesem rezept hier
wird einfach die ganze packung dann
müsst ihr euch im april vorarbeit
manchmal habe ich wirklich so 80 gramm
weniger manchmal ich 60 grad mehr da
müsste einfach schauen am ende mit dem
ohrläppchen trick gucken ob sich der
teig die ohrläppchen anfühlt dann ist er
genau richtig
[Musik]
mein tag ist jetzt perfekt original wie
ein ohrläppchen ihr müsst das echt mal
fühle ich dass männer interessant so und
jetzt machen befolgen dass das ganze
muss jetzt schön ruhen und auf geht's
ihm eine tankkarte teil jetzt einfach
mal dem teig in der hälfte durch machen
nämlich eine noch richtig lecker
schafskäse väter füllung das ist auch so
typisch türkisch natürlich auch in den
balkanländern und so beliebt dass und
die andere füllungen wir dann mit
kartoffeln seien sondern gerne auch noch
mal ganz grob zu einer kugel formen
und dann wirklich in zwei separaten
schüssel entgehen lassen ich bin immer
fan davon weil der teig der sollte jetzt
nicht zu viel mehr enthalten entweder
gibt jeder ganz wenig mehl in die
schüssel aber wirklich sehr vorsichtig
dass wir da nicht zuviel hat mal
umdrehen ist ja noch was bestreuen oder
ihr nehmt euch back trend spray er mache
ich jetzt so und unser back tritt will
ist es nur ein prototyp deswegen einfach
nur mal die grafik von hamza
draufgeklebt das ist endlich ohne
alkohol endlich doch ist das erste
überhaupt ohne alkohol und da mal ganz
langsam gearbeitet und das kommt auch
ganz bald es hat euch auf dem laufenden
können wir gerne auf instagram folgen da
gibt es nämlich solche infos immer so
jetzt den teig hier eingeben
und dann brauchen wir eine stunde ruhe
an einem warmen ort wo es nicht zieht
ihr könnt doch einfach in den backofen
schon weil ich hab eine offene küche und
im backofen bin ich mir sicher dass es
nicht zieht noch einmal ein buch drüber
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder
beziehungsweise wir bereiten jetzt die
füllung vor
[Musik]
ich starte jetzt mit der kartoffel
füllung dafür habe ich einfach
kartoffeln geschält und in kochendem
wasser gegart das hat so ungefähr 14 15
minuten gedauert deshalb habe ich ja
auch vorher ein bisschen größer also
kleiner geschnitten damit schneller geht
und jetzt machen wir sind weiter mit der
kartoffel füllung indem wir einfach eine
zwiebel schön fein hacken und dann geht
das ganze in gutow leven öl angedünstet
zusammen mit knoblauch da kommt dann
auch paprika markt dazu ende kein
paprika magda habt dann könnt automaten
markt nehmen ja und damit das alles
richtig schön gedünstet bis es so
zerfällt und weich wird und danach
machen wir schon weiter mit den
kartoffeln
[Musik]
die zwiebel masse ist jetzt fertig und
mit dem olivenöl nicht sparen wir wollen
ja gleich keine trockene füllung sondern
eine die wirklich einfach so ein
bisschen feuchtigkeit hat das bekommt
ihr ganz gut ebene durch das olivenöl
ist die bezieher die kartoffeln einfach
in eine schüssel und dann braucht ihr
die jetzt nicht zu püree verarbeitet
sondern einfach nur ganz grob stampfen
ihr könntet ihr zum beispiel auch eine
gabel nehmen und da geben wir dann quasi
die sieben asse ryan gerne noch ein
bisschen olivenöl dazu dann könnt ihr
dann selber schauen ob das genug drin
ist oder ob es noch ein bisschen was
braucht und bei mir darf petersilie nie
fehlen deshalb habe ich auch schon
petersilie gehackt und gleich auch für
beide füllungen also gleich wie
schafskäse mischung kommt auf jeden fall
auch noch petersilie mit rein und hier
könnt ihr jetzt noch würzen natürlich
mit salz und pfeffer und ich nehme jetzt
ganz gerne mein hakuna matata gewürzt
wenn ihr das nicht da habt dann könnt
ihr auch zum beispiel paprikapulver
edelsüß nehmen oder er gibt ein bisschen
rosmarin dazu das schreibe ich aber
alles unten in der infobox
[Musik]
[Applaus]
beide schaffst diese füllung einmal nur
den schafskäse mit der gabel zerdrücken
petersilie dazugeben und so war sie
eigentlich schon fertig ihr müsst es
nicht würzen denn der käse ist schon
witzig genug wenn ihr jetzt auch im
kühlschrank in die käse habe den ihr
verwerten müsst dann könnte gerne den
einfach so ein bisschen klein schneiden
und mit dazu geben oder ihr könnt direkt
auch käsereien reiben wenn ihr das nicht
habt wenn es die füllung aus so auch
schon komplett in ordnung und in der
zwischenzeit ist der teig auch schon
aufgegangen das heißt wir machen gleich
schon direkt mit dem teig weiter
[Musik]
wir schnappen uns jetzt zuallererst
einen teig und teilen ihn durch 12 bzw
ich habe anschließend noch einmal
abgewogen und jedes teiglingen hat bei
mir zwischen 65 und 70 gramm gewogen ich
zehn mal schnell für euch ab also in
bekommt halt auch nicht immer die
gleiche anzahl raus letzten 2012 heute
sind 246 8 14 habe ich heute raus
bekommt wenn ihr euch daran halte zu 65
bis 70 gramm finde ich persönlich jetzt
perfekt so als größte und ich starte
jetzt direkt in dem ich so die
klassischste aller formen mache das ist
so diese typische portscher formen nimmt
euch jetzt den teig und er braucht noch
nicht mal in bienen aus hollstadt dafür
muss zusehen dass ich die immer schön
bedecken lasse und dann nehmt ihr euch
einfach die finger des super fluffig
dass merkel jetzt schon einfluss und den
fingern ein bisschen oval ausbreiten so
auch gerne etwas dicker lassen und jetzt
nehmen wir uns zuallererst die kartoffel
füllungen geben das in die mitte an den
seiten oben und unten schön frei lassen
und jetzt nehmen wir uns einfach unsere
finger und drücken quasi die enden so
aneinander dass es zusammenhält und wenn
ihr das dann umdreht und habt ihr
einfach so eine richtig schöne ovale
klassische porsche form
[Musik]
ich habe meine zwei bäche jetzt schon
fertig bzw die variante mit der
kartoffel füllung es ist immer besser
wenn ihr den jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen ruhe gönnt also wenn ihr da
manchmal zugedeckt 15 minuten wartet ist
das ein erheblicher unterschied nach dem
backen das wird noch mal so richtig
flüssig und ich mache jetzt aber in der
zwischenzeit schon mal den bus nicht den
großen kuchen bank ich mache einfach
schon mal die ich mir schon fertig die
man so kennt beide becken damit einfach
noch mal schön aussieht also im
geschmack macht jetzt nichts und ich hab
noch mal einen extra tipp für euch hat
das jetzt mit der gabel zu verquirlen
püriert er das tatsächlich einmal kurz
denn dann gelernt das gebäck nach dem
backen noch besser und ich mache sogar
so dass ich oben drüber noch ein
bisschen sesam streue oder ich mach es
anders und damit man es von außen auch
erkennt kommen auf die kartoffel port
said einfach schwarzkümmel sein und
gleich gefühl ich im anschluss direkt
die mit käse und da macht denn im
anschluss einfach lesen
[Musik]
die käse teigtaschen sind jetzt auch
fertig die bucks verwertung gar nicht
verraten dies aber für alle bleche
gleich und ihr könnt auch immer nur ein
blech im ofen backen und nicht in
mehrere gleichzeitig weil für mehrere
bleche braucht die haltung los und um
luft wieder das gebäck austrocknen wir
backen bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze
wichtig ist dass in den ofen vor haid
und da brauchen die teigtaschen 22
minuten ist kann sein dass sie mal ein
zwei minuten länger brauchen sie dürfen
aber nicht zu dunkel werden
[Musik]
ich habe potter gemacht okay also
einfach nicht gesehen habe ich gewusst
das ist dass deutschland ja das aber
nicht sagen ob du bescheid ist ja eine
frage das woran das du denken wenn ich
besser sagen
gleich
nicht in porta denke denke ich immer an
das wort fluffig das ist wieso auch
sofort das war doch mal was
denkst du eigentlich wenig potter sagen
würden zusammen sagen den orden sind 123
wirklich
weiters hat diesen harmonieren richtig
so wer weiß wie schwimm und so auf der
wellenlänge also keyboard schon gemacht
wir müssen halt was machst du da machst
du diese ausfallschritte dass man
ehrlich ist doch einfach nur so machen
wie ich gegen brewster so
probieren durch offene probiere ich
einfach machen wir die offenen richter
damals haben sie dann schon wieder schon
okay mit schwarzkümmel natürlich wollen
wir diesen mit jetzt sogar ein komplott
mehr gelten der wohl noch
häufig schon ein paar saft war flüchtig
sein urgroßvater sein
ururgroßvater ausdenken norm liga
bekamen geige wird sich die bekannte
feature freeze einfach eine wolke die
wirklich besuchen
wo also ich hab das nicht mehr gehörten
da hat einfach der käse eigengeschmack
also ich würd sagen leute also das ist
eigentlich mal das ist einfach wenn man
das wahrscheinlich nach dem rezept nach
dann bist du einfach der king zuhause
ist mein ball direkt pluspunkte familie
schwiegermama mann frau egal was keine
ahnung tochter wenn euch lieber für mega
ich wünsche euch viel spaß und ich gönne
mir das jetzt richtig am besten mit
türkischen tee das ist so typisch der
klassiker ich mache mir natürlich kennt
nicht für mich ist es super also leute
einfach mal nachmachen leuten ja hat er
bisher dran geblieben ist und alles
gerückt hat der sollte jetzt auch
wirklich
vorausgegangen seien ja nur eine sekunde
zeit also bis zum nächsten haus auch
kein geld das wichtig ja sonst ja
die spitze
[Musik]